[Music]
frank herbert's dune has been adapted
once again for the big screen and you've
never seen the story play out like this
to help unpack part one of this sci-fi
masterpiece in the making here are some
of the small details you might have
missed in dune
one of the most surprising parts of dune
that goes relatively unnoticed is that
there aren't any computers in the
universe or at least not as we know them
sure there's basic technology that
relays information for the user but
there's no smart tech or artificial
intelligence to assist with space travel
and absolutely no processing machines
capable of executing computation even
the ornithopters those bird-like planes
flown by the atreides rely entirely on
the reaction speed eyesight and
navigational skills of their pilots we
even see paul at one point using a
paracompass which duncan idaho describes
as a clever piece of clockwork to
straighten his path through the desert
to put it simply the technology in dune
feels awfully analog it's a science
fantasy aesthetic lifted straight from
the source material which went on to
leave a serious imprint on the genre
inspiring legions of imitators most
famously george lucas's star wars but
why society is clearly very advanced
thanks to the huge spaceships used by
the great houses to ship troops and
spice across the universe this is a
truly interstellar civilization set in
the far future and with not as much as
an apple iii computer to show for it
there's a reason for that thousands of
years before the events of dune humans
waged war across the universe with a
malevolent a.i called omnius who rose to
take advantage of the fact that humanity
had become reliant on thinking machines
the 2002 novel dune the butlerian jihad
published after frank herbert's death
and written by his son brian herbert and
author kevin j anderson kicks off a
trilogy about this crusade to free the
universe from the malevolent computers
that had penetrated every facet of
modern life there are workarounds for
the modern citizen and dune however
although it's never directly explained
in the film through fear hawaii and
pieter de vries are both mentats mentats
are extremely intelligent people who
have been conditioned to hold vast
amounts of knowledge and execute
advanced computations as flesh and bone
replacements for thinking machines in
short in the universe of dune computers
are forbidden by interstellar law
fear might be the mind killer but the
slow blade penetrates the shield
although the personal shields that dunes
characters use are good for deflecting
projectiles they leave the user
vulnerable to slow moving handheld
weapons house atreides weapon master
gurney holik warns paul about these
vulnerabilities in the training scene
early on in the film and even shows him
that immediately going for a killing
blow while wearing a shield can still
lead to defeat as he puts it the slow
blade penetrates the shield this is why
fencing and swordplay have become
integral skills for soldiers in dunes
universe while guns and other larger
incendiary devices have been mostly
relegated to space ship to ship and
air-to-ground warfare the swordplay also
adds an element of elegance to the
universe making the act of waging war an
incredibly personal thing outside of
their vehicles soldiers and commanders
have to face their opponents directly on
the battlefield duncan idaho and gurney
are both incredibly gifted swordsmen
moving their weapons fast enough to
catch the enemy off guard but slow
enough to penetrate the shield it's a
delicate dance of violence unique to the
combat aesthetic of dune of course it
isn't just swords and knives that can
slowly break through the shield the
remotely piloted hunter seeker can
pierce its defenses using a tiny needle
filled with lethal venom dr yue is also
seen using a notable slow-moving
projectile to drill through duke leto's
shield paralyzing him on behalf of baron
harkonnen
hausa tradies is one of the most noble
houses in the universe and has plenty of
support throughout the imperium so it's
understandable why the emperor is scared
of duke leto and his family the
atreide's name carries weight throughout
the galaxy but why all the bull
symbolism we first see a carving of a
man fighting a bull at the site of
paul's grandfather's grave ledo mentions
that his father was killed fighting a
bull so maybe this carving is just a
tribute but then we see a bull's head
again hanging in the etredes palace on
kaladan the totem is important enough
for them to box up and take with them to
arrakis turns out this isn't just any
old bull the seleucin bull is famous in
the history of house of tradies mainly
because letto's father paulus etredes
was killed by one during a bullfighting
match the solution bull is notorious for
its anger and violent temperament so
paulus clearly enjoyed the wilder side
of life perhaps duke leto kept the head
to remind him not to be as headstrong as
his father
very early in the film we're introduced
to an aspect of paul's character that
really makes up the core of the story
though you might not realize it from
part one while still on kaladan paul is
beset by vivid dreams that seem to
trouble his mother and attract the
attentions of the benny jesseret in
these dreams paul sees war he sees
arrakis he sees the death of a tradies
champion duncan idaho he sees a girl in
a still suit who looks a lot like
zendaya as we know from the back half of
the movie all of these dreams come to
pass and paul ultimately meets the
zendaya looking fremont girl named chani
[Music]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them yes
there's a brief moment in the film
related to these visions that's easy to
miss it happens when paul runs out into
the desert to rescue a crew of spice
miners under threat of worm sign sand
kicked up by the approaching worm swirls
around paul and gurney hallock and in
that sand we see golden moats flickering
the movie's visual cue for the presence
of spice this is the moment in the film
when paul gets his first large dose of
the ambient spice that saturates the
deep deserts of arrakis the spice
awakens paul's latent powers of prophecy
there's something away from my mind the
spice doesn't cause paul's power of
prophecy that's all the result of the
beni jesuit breeding program and
jessica's decision to defy her order and
bear duke leto a son but its regular
application does awaken and sharpen the
ability that will become the atreides
blessing and curse for the next several
millennia
the duke's son sees too much
in one of paul's waking visions we see
paula tradies fighting for arrakis with
the bright blue on blue eyes of the
indigenous fremen while it's no stretch
to imagine paul fighting with the fremen
considering how part one ends paul's
eyes are typically brown so how did this
ocular switch happen as we will no doubt
discover in the second half of
villeneuve's adaptation the blue on blue
look that's so in vogue in the fremen
sieges is no genetic marker it can
happen to anyone after prolonged
exposure to the spice the spice is
everywhere in the deep deserts of
arrakis it's in the air the fremen
breathe the water they drink they even
cook it into their food aside from the
obvious health benefits it turns their
irises and sclera a glowing shade of
blue when the film ends paul tells his
mother that his path goes through the
desert if that path is long enough he's
going to wind up with blue eyes just
like in his vision
after the reverend mother of the benny
jesseret pays a visit to paul on kaladan
with a very nasty present she makes an
offhand comment to jessica that a path
has been cleared for them through
arrakis in hindsight this might seem
like the height of sarcasm since we know
the reverend mother was simultaneously
conspiring with the harkonnens to murder
most of house atreides it's actually a
more important line than you might think
as it provides the connective tissue
between a few more strange and disparate
occurrences throughout the film consider
shout out mape's religious fervor after
presenting jessica with the chris knife
during what is ostensibly her interview
to become a maid liet kinds and
stilgar's suspicion that jessica and
paul satisfy some kind of prophecy and
that paul might be the freman messiah
and stilgar's use of the term sayadina
which he applies to jessica after seeing
her benny jesseret skills all of these
events are part of the path that the
benny jesseret cleared for jessica and
paul a benny jesserit initiative known
as the missionaria protectiva seeds
primitive cultures with benny jessrite
rituals so that if a sister in trouble
stumbles upon them she might be able to
con her way into being revered as a holy
woman the missionaria protectiva touched
the fremen which is why they consider a
weirding woman like jessica to be some
kind of anointed priestess jessica knows
the right words to say to set shadowed
mape's wailing because shout out mape's
entire faith is largely a construct of
the beni jesseret it may seem a cruel
tactic but the fremen are about to turn
this conjob on the benny jesuit in a big
way so stay tuned dune part 2 can't come
soon enough check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]